muitas pessoas me perguntam como é ser
delegada de polícia como é chefe ar uma
delegacia humanidade que é eminentemente
operacional como a delegacia de
homicídios onde hoje eu trabalho me
respeitam se fazem gracinhas
se eu sofrer ameaças durante muito tempo
a resposta que eu dava era curta e
grossa
homens e mulheres são iguais na polícia
eu demorei para perceber que essa não
era a resposta certa mas pra falar pra
vocês de como eu cheguei até essa
compreensão eu vou trazer um pouco da
minha trajetória
eu sou formado em direito e durante a
minha faculdade eu fiz alguns estágios
eu fiz estágio em um escritório de
advocacia e logo foi para um estágio na
delegacia onde eu fiquei por dois anos e
na delegacia eu me deparava com pessoas
que procuravam essa unidade é a
delegacia como único recurso disponível
e eu vi o quanto as nossas ações desde
as mais simples até aquelas que
decorriam de complexas investigações
tinham o poder de fazer a diferença na
vida das pessoas e é isso que me move
até hoje a possibilidade de estar diante
de dramas individuais e sociais e fazer
algo por eles
bom é depois de formada enquanto ainda
estava estudando naquela época eu morava
com meus pais eu era sustentada por eles
guiada e orientada por eles e não foi
uma tarefa muito fácil convencê-los de
que essa era minha paixão e que seria
minha escolha
na verdade eram eles que tentavam me
convencer do contrário e eles usaram
argumentos bastante convincentes
comigo eles me dariam um carro se eu
saísse daquele estádio pra dentro da
delegacia e fosse para um novo estágio
eles queriam que eu conheci outras áreas
que o direito oportuniza vá existe uma
certa razão
e com todo esse poder de convencimento
eu aceitei e fui feliz da vida pelo meu
novo estágio com o meu primeiro carro
eu não esqueço e os meus amigos nós
temos até nome para o carro a cada
lombada que passava abrir o porta malas
do carro e eu tinha que esperar o
próximo quebra molas para fechar a
experiência nesse estágio ela foi muito
boa mas nem isso nem o carro novo foram
suficientes para me demover da idéia de
ser delegado de polícia
bom depois que terminei a faculdade eu
fui fazer cursinho para concurso público
e também teve um acordo com os meus pais
que eu tentaria outros concursos que eu
não faria só concurso para a carreira
policial eu abri meu leque ea tentar
concurso para o ministério público para
a magistratura da defensoria pública
e mais uma vez eu concordei com eles mas
nunca eu fiz nenhum outro concurso senão
para delegado de polícia civil
e essa é a minha turma de formação na
escola de polícia civil no ano de 2009
quando eu entrei para a polícia aqui no
estado do paraná
as mulheres representavam algo em torno
de 10% do quadro de delegados num
universo de mais ou menos 300 delegados
era possível conhecer cada uma daquelas
mulheres e saberem que delegasse elas
estavam
hoje passados quase dez anos o número de
mulheres na polícia quase dobrou
nós somos 397 delegados sendo 74
mulheres mas ainda assim não somos nem
20% do total do quadro muito embora o
número de mulheres seja
pressenti que o cenário esteja mudando a
figura da mulher na polícia ela ainda
está muito vinculada a determinadas
atividades ou mesmo delegacias algo como
para as mulheres uma coisinha mais light
a regra é que a mulher delegada de
polícia quando ingressa ela vai para uma
delegacia da mulher uma delegacia do
adolescente um núcleo de proteção a
crianças vítimas de crimes que ela não
dá conta logo de cara de uma delegacia
que exige um potencial mais
investigativo ea minha trajetória
começou exatamente em uma delegacia da
mulher onde entre idas e vindas e eu
fiquei por um pouquinho mais de quatro
anos quando eu estava na delegacia da
mulher
eu sempre tentava fazer alguma coisa
diferente uma investigação diferente ou
responder por alguma outra delegacia que
ninguém mais queria lá tava il e foi
buscando esse meu desejo que era de
estar em uma delegacia mais
investigativa que houve vários nãos até
conseguiu sim eles me falavam mas porque
quer sair dessa delegacia você tá tão
bem onde você está
mas lá e ter essas delegacias têm tanta
exposição é tão desgastante
você quer trabalhar mais só tem homem lá
no fundo
a leitura que eu fazia é que talvez um
recado fosse você a mulher em seu lugar
não ela você pode não dar conta desse
trabalho mas foi graças à minha
insistência ea pessoas que acreditaram
em mim que em novembro de 2013
eu fui designado como titular da
delegacia de homicídios aqui de cascavel
onde estou até hoje há cinco anos e
refletindo sobre essas questões que pra
mim ficavam implícitas ea leitura que eu
fazia delas eu percebi que não adianta
falarmos que a polícia não é um ambiente
predominantemente masculino assim como
outros setores profissionais e sociais
também são fato é que nós mulheres
nesses espaços para termos o mesmo
conceito que os homens precisamos fazer
mais para demonstrarmos que somos tão
capazes quanto esses mesmos homens
o caminho é árduo mas depois que nós
alcançamos respeito que nós mostramos a
nossa capacidade
eles nos enxergam de uma forma diferente
e as coisas ficam um pouco mais
equilibradas mas não a ponto de dizermos
que homens e mulheres na polícia são
iguais
falar isso é propagar preconceito e era
isso que eu fazia lá no começo quando eu
dava aquela resposta curta e grossa
nós mulheres somos diferentes e
reconhecer as nossas diferenças
é o que vai nos trazer a igualdade é o
que vai nos fazer fortes e eu falo aqui
das diferenças óbvias entre homens e
mulheres das diferenças consagradas
genéticas biológicas porque meu objetivo
não é fazer um emblemático discurso
feminista e também não é iniciar uma
discussão
o que eu aprendi ao longo desses meus
anos na atividade policial é que não
vale a pena nós dizermos que nós
mulheres somos plenamente iguais porque
nós não somos eu penso que nós temos que
fazer é identificar no espaço que nós
estamos na atividade profissional que
nós estamos desenvolvendo do que as
nossas diferenças podem interferir no
que elas podem ser um ponto fraco e pra
isso eu vou trazer alguns exemplos da
minha atividade profissional
eu sou mulher sou policial
vou pra rua e que fazem uma abordagem
não adianta
nessa situação a mulher baixinha
policial falando mole polícia mão na
cabeça a chance de levarem isso a sério
época então numa situação como essa a
minha voz de comando ela tem que ser um
diferencial
eu alcançar o meu objetivo e até mesmo
para desistimular uma eventual reação
porque imaginem só
se a pessoa que a gente vai abordar tem
a intenção de reagir e tomar a arma de
um desses policiais estou eu a mulher e
um colega policial o homem quem vocês
acham que vai ser o preferido do
abordado o homem ou a mulher pelas suas
próprias diferenças
é uma grande chance de ser a mulher
então sabedoria disso eu vou adotar um
comportamento diferente eu não vou
chegar falando mole eu vou mostrar que
eu estou ali sou baixinha sou policial
mas eu não estou para brincadeira então
eu vou chegar à linha e às vezes mesmo
fazendo tudo isso não dá certo
já aconteceu comigo uma situação que eu
estava na delegacia da mulher
a investigadora andréia trabalhou comigo
lá e hoje também está na delegacia de
homicídios
nós temos que cumprir o mandado de
prisão fizemos todo um acompanhamento
avistamos a pessoa chegando em casa em
uma moto
demos a voz de abordagem nos
identificamos seguindo todo aquele
protocolo padrão com toda firmeza e
sujeito ficou ali paralisado em cima da
moto
a gente repetiu a voz de abordagem
apresentou as armas e nada a gente
hoje eu tenho certeza que ele estava
achando que era uma pegadinha ele não
acreditava que estava sendo abordado por
dois policiais mulheres
então o que eu procuro fazer sabendo
dessas diferenças sabendo que isso pode
acontecer
eu procuro não formar a equipe se
exclusivamente por mulheres não pela
capacidade mas sim por este cenário que
pode acontecer outra coisa que eu também
aprendi ao longo do tempo é que não
preciso fazer uma coisa exatamente do
mesmo jeito que um homem faz ser tão boa
quanto ele
eu posso fazer do meu jeito desde que
alcance o objetivo no nosso dia a dia no
nosso trabalho
nós temos situações de cumprimento de
mandados de prisão mandados de busca e
apreensão que pode surgir a necessidade
de pular um muro
no começo eu achava que eu ia ter que
pular todos os muros que aparecessem
pela frente sem a ajuda de ninguém
porque eu estava assustada com esse novo
universo com o qual me deparava sedenta
de aceitação
hoje eu sei que não é demérito nenhum se
eu pedi pra alguém me dar um pezinho a
lhe procurar esse muro porque a única
coisa que eu preciso fazer é tá do outro
lado do muro junto com os outros
policiais com a minha equipe com os meus
colegas inclusive a gente treinar
técnicas pra pular esse muro de forma
mais rápida com a ajuda dos outros
policiais
o que eu sei é que eu não posso ficar
por último na hora de pular esse muro
porque senão não vai ter ninguém para me
fazer o dito pezinho né isso que eu falo
de identificar as nossas diferenças e
não deixar que elas nos prejudique
outra coisa que existe ali no meio
policial é a questão da vaidade da
feminilidade
eu nunca me considerei uma mulher
vaidosa mas eu confesso que depois que
eu entrei na polícia um pouco de vaidade
que eu tinha ficou ainda mais reprimido
é algumas vezes eu decidi passar um
batom ou me arrumar e ouvia comentários
como nossa essa delegada perde mais
tempo escolhendo a cor do batom do que
prendendo investigando pessoas e isso
doía isso me machucava
isso incomodava
e não foram poucas as vezes que deixem
de passar batom deixei de me arrumar
por causa disso quando eu fazia quando
adotava esse comportamento
eu estava cedendo a um preconceito e com
isso eu deixava eu replicável esse
preconceito e deixava ele ainda mais
forte
hoje eu luto para que ele não me
aprisione mais porque eu sei que muitas
de nós mulheres
fazemos mais no nosso trabalho e ainda
temos tempo de escolher a cor do nosso
button então eu tenho direito de exercer
a minha feminilidade à medida que eu
achar adequada
o meu espaço um exemplo disso foi o que
aconteceu pra minha preparação aqui pra
excited x eu tinha que escolher algumas
fotos para encaminhar para a organização
e ao invés de pegar e dá um google que
escolheu uma foto qualquer eu decidir
que eu ia fazer uma foto especial pra
isso eu me permitir é mostrar trazer à
tona meu lado profissional ea minha
feminilidade
então eu fui no salão fiz maquiagem e
tirei essa foto especial fazer isso pra
mim foi um grande desafio
foi me deparar com um preconceito talvez
inconsciente e me despi dele
outra reflexão que eu tive foi trazida
pela débora uma acadêmica de direito que
trabalha comigo na delegacia
todo ano é a delegacia de homicídios
busca fazer uma ação social é
pretendendo uma aproximação da polícia
com a comunidade
no final do ano passado nós fomos até
uma creche onde levamos brinquedos para
as crianças os meninos nós levamos
carrinhos e para as meninas carros de
polícia e para as meninas nós levamos
bonecas e a deborah me fez parar pra
pensar no tamanho dessa incoerência
o que nós não levamos carrinhos de
polícia também para as meninas
justo eu delegada de polícia
apaixonada pelo que faço que não me vejo
fazendo outra coisa que já há uns bons
anos
estou neste universo experimentando as
alegrias e as dificuldades
às vezes é preciso parar parar para
refletir nas ações que repetimos
automaticamente para talvez fazer uma
história diferente mas com certeza uma
história mais justa
leve uma coisa eu posso assegurar a
vocês que na ação deste ano todas as
crianças meninos e meninas vão receber
carrinho de polícia
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]